[Musique]
google qui a été victime d'une panne
massive hier à travers le monde et la
panne n'a duré qu'une heure mais a
touché tous les services de google le
moteur de recherche mais aussi les mails
la plateforme de vidéos youtube qui
appartient à google et globalement on se
rend compte que sans google la vie est
un peu plus compliqué sur internet g1
partiel sur zoom mais le lien est dans
mes mails
impossible d'y accéder s'inquiète une
étudiante est ce que les youtuber vont
bénéficier du chômage partiel demande un
internaute vos clients s'adressent
toujours avoué nouveau rôle de
commissaire-priseur je crois
qu'aujourd'hui certains sont
complètement perdus sans google aux
états unis de nombreux cours en ligne
ont été annulés hier matin et dans
certaines villes les crèches n'ont pas
pu ouvrir
illustration de l'impact de l'emprise
très concrète de google sur nos vies on
parle d'une panne d'à peine une heure je
vous laisse imaginer cela avait duré et
applaudissements c'est une denrée rare
il faut en profiter
ce matin j'étais chez mon dentiste
il m'a dit tu veux un café dit ouais je
peux boire un café nulle part en fait on
t'offre à café aujourd'hui c'est génial
ici tout a été pensé pour nuire à la
santé
on lui fait la promotion des cigarettes
les cocktails sont servis dans des
boîtes de médicaments et le vin sous
forme de perfusion
le fast food se targue même de combattre
l'anorexie depuis 2005
bienvenue dans ma chambre bonbons
il ya plus de 1800 kilos de bonbons rien
que dans ma chambre
c'était beaucoup pas vrai un jour je
prendrai un marteau et j'explose vrai
tout ça ce sera cool et si vous ne
terminez pas votre assiette vous avez le
droit à une fessée en public il était
trop belle pour faire ça et la fesse
gauche maintenant
voilà la deuxième
[Musique]
pour la première fois ce soir on est
évidemment des confiné et on est sous
couvre-feu
j'espère que vous avez tous aux
attestations autrement vous m'appelez
vous appeler si vous êtes arrêté par les
policiers vous appeler pour vous dire
que vous étiez dans une émission de t
oui monsieur près vous réagir en fait la
personne réagit ce soir bon voulait
faire les moeurs sincères et moi ça
c'est un petit peu comme un chien de
garde
il se sent en danger je pense qu'il
n'est pas bien ce soir macias est censé
être là pour moi après aller de dire
fois je suis battu je ne dis pas que je
n'étais pas ton frère et le père noël
hospitalisé en service de réanimation l'
agence de santé britannique voulait
marquer les esprits et rendre hommage au
personnel médical mobilisé dans la lutte
contre le coronavirus même si le spot se
finit bien
il a provoqué un tollé sur les réseaux
sociaux outre-manche des parents se
disent choqués et craignent que leurs
enfants soient traumatisés
seuls des psychopathes peur peuvent
faire cela aux enfants combien d'enfants
vont finir en larme en pensant que le
père noël va mourir à reste que c'est
exagéré
pas pour la thérapeute zoé cloud
spécialistes spécialiste du traumatisme
et de l'anxiété qui explique dans le
daily mail que cette publicité est
susceptible de causer de graves dommages
aux esprit jeune et impressionnable
impôts sont depuis l'association a dû
retirer le spot est présenté ses excuses
le père noël est il une île nous avons
eu une discussion rapide avec lui et il
va très bien
c'est monsieur va très bien il est très
occupé en ce moment mais il est immunisé
et de nombreux chefs d'états dans le
monde nous ont fait savoir qu'il sera
exempté de 40 ans donc il pourra entrer
et sortir de l'espace aérien
il sera en mesure de livrer les cadeaux
et si vous le pouvez d'ailleurs c'est ce
qui se pratique dans certains pays
étrangers dont beaucoup auto confiné
vous huit jours avant noël si vous
pouvez ce n'est pas possible vous
admiriez cette recommandation bien
entendu pourtant à chaque fois que cela
est possible surtout si on doit recevoir
pas noël des personnes vulnérables
on reste à distance on regarde un masque
et quand on va manger la bûche
et paf et à l'erreur de mon collègue
mais on s'éloigne pourquoi pour la bûche
ou pour le reste aussi
pour le reste pour tous sawicki surtout
les tests ils sont utiles si vous êtes
symptomatique sinon sinon c'est pas un
totem le test peut vous faire tester le
vendredi mais être contagieux être
positif le lundi il faudrait le faire
presque tous les deux jours ça n'est pas
possible ce n'est pas raisonnable
d'autant que nous n'aurions pas la
capacité de le faire
baratineur baratineur pas de réponse 500
euros j'avais compris que la semaine
dernière ont lancé des tests massy voir
systématique et wavre à roubaix s'est
pas entraîné et là j'entends ça sert à
rien donc on dépensera combien de
millions de dizaines de millions
d'années millions pour un truc inutile
dans ces cas là tu avais il ya un film
de michel audiard sait pas quand c'est
pas quand on n'a rien à dire c'est pas
parce qu'on a rien à dire qu'il faut
fermer sa gueule mais parfois je crois
que sinon celle où il se contredit
on a entendu la voix jean-pierre ta voix
inimitable
mais ce que vous saviez aussi qu'il
était très très drôle regardez jean
pierre j'ai retrouvé ça au nom j'étais
fan de johnny des soirées musique
autrefois on le voit un tatouage tee
shirt et allart johnny
je suis désolé je vais parcourir
l'europe avec ce truc sur la jambe
[Musique]
chut
elle m'a dit tu as bien assez de rubans
de chaussures et de vêtements
et donc elle m'a offert ça regardez un
peu
attendez-vous à let avec mon visage
absolument partout j'ai des chiffres des
gueux tatoué sur la jambe comme tu crois
qu'elle va réussir à le pardonner sur sa
colas va falloir que je trouve une
solution
tu sais pourquoi il a fait ça un jour
j'ai oublié tirer la chasse une seule
fois tu as oublié tirer la chasse aux
qu'il faut croire que ça n'arrivera plus
jamais avec ce tatouage
je vais vous apprendre un truc de dingue
mais figurez-vous qui a pas de retour en
arrière alors français le temps file
profiter et on se fout du regard des
autres
soyez vous même merci à vous ne vous en
faites pas trop
soyez bien et je vous embrasse très fort
[Applaudissements]